oh so the latest art so I got the chair
and the burial comes back she goes what
is this and I'm like it's a free chair I
thought she would be hyped about it
because it's a free chair but she's what
she says she goes you don't get
furniture in this house without asking
me first
it's my house as well well guess what
the chair is still here [ __ ] and I just
to keep but she watched this podcast I
hope not the chair still here and now I
I don't even like that chair that much I
sit on it every day just to prove a
point you petty
oh I'm petty why I'm straight petty wat
that's my chair that's a free as good
chair I think we bond on our page whop
Oh 100%
yeah amen like high school was such a
trip for us too we were talking about on
the podcast before this before didn't
get retorted retorting retorted we had
an educator you know me crying before
they getting over story oh you were
taught it but we had we had a high
school reunion and a high school reunion
was so funny because man it was such an
odd experience for us because number one
when I pictured a high school reunion I
pictured it I pictured it like the stuff
that I saw on the movies in the movies
right now you'll see a couple of people
that probably didn't look as spiffy as
they did before there was but there was
other people that would bloom and look
better
yeah but I walked in that place and
everybody looked like [ __ ] I was like we
boomed comparatively speaking right so I
went back and I was like some y'all are
very interesting good we had a few
friends that still lived in high school
they would talk about high school like
it was the peak of their their lives
which is funny because high school was
not a peak for me at all it was one of
those moments that I wanted to move past
and then just start fresh again I mean
it's the only system where it was almost
like it's like the factory anyways it's
it's basically like we have we have it's
like a mass you know production of
education we don't have anything catered
nothing is catered jessica lee we're all
in the same school we're doing all the
same regimen and then when you get out
of high school you get it choose your
path it just like no freedom we just
basically mass-market school schooling
and yeah unless you're at a waldorf or
some like Montessori or whatever and
your parents were fortunate enough to
get you into one of those educational
systems like you're in the public
education system you just you're eating
whatever they shove down your throat
yeah so I think like for most people
like creatives like yourself it's not
gonna be a great atmosphere except for
the jokes jokes and the stories the
jokes are the best and the stories are
the best yeah we had such a I had such
an eclectic group of friends when I look
back at it I think the cool thing about
high school or the way that I chose to
navigate through high school I had a lot
of different friends like I didn't
really stick to one group I think I just
generally got along with a lot of people
up to a certain extent as I had my
really close friends there and they were
really good people but I also had like
these anime nerd geek friends and then I
also had a bunch of certainly certainly
a journalist friends I love it the
cherish ones no do you remember [ __ ]
I mean I'm pretty sure he's pretty well
now but this guy oh let's not say his
name but because he might watch the [ __ ]
but he was so [ __ ] annoying when he
looked like he was a indian cat oh yeah
but there was one cat that used to
[ __ ] piss me off in high school you
know he not just pissed me off he would
piss everybody off yeah because he was
such a habitual [ __ ] liar yeah and
you know growing up as a kid my dad
[ __ ] hated lying so much he would
beat my ass consistently is that why is
that why you'd be my eyes I want our I
beat your ass for lying about the
watermelon slices you stupid son of a
[ __ ]
yo first of all we got to get people
contacts can't just jump into the what
so one time when me and David hanging
out early in our relationship like a gay
couple the anniversary am anniversary
anyways like we're hanging out at
David's house we after school
eat some watermelon slices like some
young man would do
I forgot you got a watermelon here I got
to go run it some people go home and
smoke
the tropical fruit yeah
so we're just eating a watermelon and
then I must I left my peel on his sink
counter and I forgot that was mine or
whatever and he's like damn whatever
like 5-10 minutes later he's like it's
an a is that show a sexual appeal and I
was like it reflexively I was like nah
and I was like and it's full proceeded
to pin my arms there and just punch me
this I'm literally beautifying me on his
arms and I started stocking his arms
until they both were dead that [ __ ] was
so I was like this guy has some issues
know about those slices first of all
Waterman boy lying and I'm glad you
found Muay Thai now he's found an outlet
for his inner rage no I hit people who
are voluntarily wanting to be hit and
you don't stab people anymore either
that's right see I've evolved as a human
being yeah he did stamp some money
elementary school bit of accident it was
a complete accident and it was well
deserved so dodge he wasn't fasting yeah
he wasn't fast no that's on you homie
yeah we blaming victims yeah you know me
Jesus pray but that was his dude in high
school not gonna say his name [ __ ]
funny how much of a habitual liar he was
he was such a bad liar that his lies
just never made any sense like everybody
would rat him out and our buddy Rene
this [ __ ] would call him out all
the time I remember he did it once it
knew it was like our English class and
he was he was basically lying about him
having a it was like a what do you call
that [ __ ] a turbo kit in his in his
silence car yeah so mind you I know for
a lot of people out there like Oh a sign
it's not a big deal but when you grow up
in a broke-ass neighbor somebody getting
a brand-new car is a big [ __ ] deal
so he had this like Scion tC and then he
was talking big [ __ ] saying like yo I
got this I got this [ __ ] turbo [ __ ]
you know you just identified
yeah in the hood everybody knows whose
car zoom in everybody know who the [ __ ]
that is but doesn't matter cat again
but either way like he would lie about
this is this [ __ ] like he would have
a turbo kit for his [ __ ] Scion and so
this dude Rene that we know he doesn't
you you want to talk you would think I'm
crass Rene is crass and Rene would get
tired of his [ __ ] so much he would
call him out he goes cool well I'm gonna
go over to your house tonight and then
we'll see that kid we'll see you let's
see you let's hook it up together
because we're named knew about cars yeah
I think those are not what I meant is
that body but it's not in yet it's like
yo bro
[ __ ] stop that [ __ ] and I remember
when the new Xbox 360 came out he was
like yo I got that new Xbox is [ __ ]
dope as hell and then hey without a
[ __ ] beat that was miss he goes cool
nah I mean I ordered it he would lie
about everything
yeah I don't know why I think high
school was like this big you know it's a
weird place of insecurities in that
those insecurities would manifest in
such weird ways yeah like you know for
that individual lying from you know
other people that be very quiet I know
you and I we had our own like personal
insecurities that we had to get harassed
but now like you know I and it and but I
do think those insecurities help kind of
form you yeah and then like how you
choose to react to them make you who you
are today yeah I don't know why he lied
but I like I can't figure out the source
I think he just had like a mental mental
problem where like he just habitually
lied about it actually carried through
college because we you actually knew
people that knew him in college really
and so one of our friends he went to
Davis oh he did he did oh yeah yeah cuz
i trick cuz I transferred in so I never
you never really crossed paths with him
but I tried he he dorm DUP with one of
our buddies he did and he told me that
eventually everybody that was living in
that house together hated him because he
got caught up in all of his lies he
would lie about everything
yeah and so people originally gravitate
toward him because he has I he's like I
guess he can't be very likable or he's
very likable guy and then after a while
like it's weird when somebody lies about
[ __ ] that clearly is a lie you know like
there's no way that any
money would believe you and so you know
people were already skeptical about the
stuff that he was saying but I guess
like finally what happened was like
people in that house just blew up at him
and they just started calling him out on
[ __ ] and he couldn't back any of the
stuff up and eventually he just had to
bounce and then nobody ever talked to
him after that but you know I forgot who
I met it recently oh I met up the guy
that lived with him because he was
visiting uh so he works for the state so
I guess he comes out to LA every now and
then and so we met up and he told me
that he's married now he has like a wife
is [ __ ] oh yeah I'm like what kind of
[ __ ] psycho [ __ ] [ __ ] marry him
you know I hope they're happy you not me
dude I wish the worst upon that
[ __ ] I hated that guy you know
something that my when I was learning
psychiatry and like it's different like
kind of personality disorders and
there's like there's different
personality types I think we all kind of
have in our head the idea of like a
narcissist and then we have people like
codependent basically they were saying
like yeah and then the psychiatrist was
she was kind of being a little facetious
but also like a lot of truth is said in
jest yeah so she's like you know
narcissist likes talking about ourselves
dismiss blah and in the codependent
you know they definitely need somebody
who's there and strong and all that it's
like you know actually narcissist it
could've been they get along quite well
as a couple and she's like just showing
that everyone for everybody who's broken
there's somebody to compliment them and
I was like and I was like oh that's kind
of beautiful you know it's funny as you
say that I actually remember why I cuz a
lot of people you know they fit man they
lie and it doesn't really bother me that
much I remember why I don't like the way
he lies I I don't I didn't like it
because when he would lie about
something he would lie about something
to make him look great and make you look
like you're beneath him yeah I have
better things than you I have nicer
things than you and I called them out on
his [ __ ] once because we were we had
the same history class and then he comes
in and he aces the test right and then
you know the the teacher comes up and he
goes hey you studied really well last
night you got a a he goes oh I didn't
read the book at all and I looked at him
I was like [ __ ] how the [ __ ] do you
know about this random stuff in world
history if you never studied it shut the
[ __ ] up
I was like yo cuz he what he wanted to
do was say that I don't study and I'm
smarter than everybody else
like bro shut the [ __ ] up yeah just just
just claim it yeah I was like yeah I
worked
hard and I did well but it was his point
to always lie about things to show that
he was better than people that's that's
the reason why would like the turbo kid
and all that - exactly it was done on
people yeah and you're saying that a
bunch of around people who don't have a
lot of money I think his parents were
decently well off compared to us yeah so
it's like now I think that's also
because we're like from like Cossack the
gutter just a lot of good news in the
world yeah but you know I would say that
we're definitely economically
[Music]
under-resourced yeah so and I think your
parents are your parents are immigrants
my parents are immigrants we didn't grow
up with much but so I think like any
time anyone treats me less than yeah and
I think you have the same trigger I
think that's why we that's why we've
well we vibe you know we just react with
what this would this would not anger but
just like just like passion yeah [ __ ]
are you better than me me [ __ ] you yeah
and and i think and i think that's like
what has served me in school i mean cuz
i mean i went their tradition around
with college i went to college then I
did undergrad that I didn't at school
after like you know going to Ecuador
yeah a bit of time that's cool and now
I'm like finishing up residency but like
part of like the biggest motivation is
like it's like ah you can't make it
because you blagging you from the other
one yeah I'm gonna be a doctor
watch me [ __ ] and then when your
children are sick I go here fake shot
supporter option to a foreign country
they don't get measles that's not true
actually that's what I would do if I was
doctor which is why I'm not a doctor
that's right dr. Jekyll mr. Hyde that's
me you know this the entertainment the
art I think you killin that game I'll do
the doc this time that's right little
children you say that and just like
stroke your wood in the booth now we're
good
what the [ __ ] will you say yeah but
either way man there was some weird
[ __ ] characters in high school been
there was this part too well I really
want to put this [ __ ] in his script but
you know we said this on the other
podcast and that was lightweight
regretting that I had mentioned this
story but I'm doing it but you're not
gonna bring it up twice yo so back in
the day right so you guys had Instagram
and also the [ __ ] where you guys would
DM each other well we had a [ __ ] called
aim and I'm pretty sure still around
when it's air well instant messenger
everybody had their weird screen names I
was like kimchi panda boy 87 or some
[ __ ] like that but there was these group
of girls that used to hang out hang out
with and they call themselves the
innocent eight it was both heard of my
life and the other guy group that we
hung out with or they hung out with them
the most they call themselves the
evolution seven just to [ __ ] with that
there's only one of them it wasn't with
like some real [ __ ] but they were saying
that the [ __ ] with them yeah but
eventually the innocent eight broke up
and the reason why they broke up this
was like the dumbest thing I've ever
heard of my life I guess some of the
girls were more close to the other girls
and so when they would go to the mall
sometimes they wouldn't invite some of
the other girls like when they go to the
mall and take those pictures with all
the smoke you know people used to give
out the their pictures of that clique
like training I got a couple myself that
I regret and then [ __ ] what happened
was I guess that kind of like came to a
head and they split and in his eighth
became the dumb [ __ ] force and so they
they split into a group of fours and at
this time this drama was some heated ass
[ __ ] because these girls some of them
they were on them on route to becoming a
valedictorians and [ __ ] yeah water girls
yeah one girl her whole family went to
our same high school she has a big-ass
family and she because of the drama that
she had with these girls didn't get to
graduate with honors because she got
into a [ __ ] fight not sure yeah it
was her and her other friend who
recently got married and
David made a some great not so covert
names for learning yeah we're just gonna
call their Vietnamese Vietnamese so
Vietnam Vietnam squared came up and so
there was a fight that they had out to
school with this [ __ ] stomped the [ __ ]
out of this other girl's head
she literally uh sure eighth house
stomped her ass out a stop like I
remember cuz the girl that she beat up
she was III think the thing that they
didn't like about it was she kind of
pretended to be a really sweet girl but
she wasn't yeah but either way that girl
could not defend herself
cuz this girl Vietnam squared e she's
wrong
yo I'm talking about if she was I
guarantee you in a previous life she was
a pit bull she yeah he [ __ ] was